دعا البيان الختامي الاجتماعي الاليه
الرباعيه لمجموعه الايجاد طرفي الصراع في
السودان الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار
والاحتكام الى الحوار والتفاوض وقد قطع
وفد الجيش السوداني الاجتماع بينما حضره
وفد لقيادات سياسيه ومدنيه سودانيه
وممثلون لقوات الدعم السريع كان هذا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارع ما
واجهت الاسباب التي دعت الجيش السوداني
لمقاطعه اجتماع الايجاد وما تاثير مقاطعات
لجيش اجتماع الاجاده على مخرجاته وما افقه
حل الازمه السودانيه في ظل انسداد جهود
التسويه وتعطل مساعي وقف اطلاق النار
وازدياد حده المواجهات
[موسيقى]
الموقف السوداني من هذه المبادره كان
معلنا رموز لتعم القمه التي انعقدت
لدوليجات في جيبوتي خواتيم الشهر الماضي
وبالتالي غياب وفد السودان وفد الجيش
السوداني عن القمه لم يكن عن هذا الاجتماع
لم يقم مفاجا وهناك
موضوعيه دفع بها الجيش السوداني وتحدثت
عنها الحكومه السودانيه اعترضت ابتداء على
رئاسه الرئيس الكيني للجنه الرباعيه وطلبه
اسنادها الى الرئيس سيلفاكير
رئيس دوله جنوب السودان وراب في الرئيس
الكيني طرفا غير محايدا تصريحات الذي صدرت
عن الرئيس الكيني قبل هذا الاجتماع كانت
عدوانيه وكانت حاده وتواصلت ايضا بعد
الاجتماع عندما تحدث عن حاجه السودان الى
قياده جديده هذا اعتبرته الحكومه
السودانيه
الرئيس الاثيوبي تحدث ايضا بطريقه غير
مقبوله وثاره حفيظه الحكومه عندما دعا الى
فرط منطقه حظر الطيران والى منع استخدام
المدفعيه الثقيله ودعك انه يريد ان يقلم
اظافره الجيش السوداني ويمنعه من استخدام
ابرز نقاط قوته الدوله الاثيوبي ايضا يتم
النظر اليه بعين الريبه
كرئيسا لهذه اللجنه الرباعيه لانه هو ليس
لديه اي حدود مباشره مع السودان فلو وضعنا
اثيوبيا كرئيس او جنوب السودان فهو لا
لديهم اعلاف الكيلومترات من الحدود
المشتركه وذلك
لم يبدو جيدا
[موسيقى]
في الاساس على عقد لقاء مباشر بين فريق
اول عبد الفتاح البرهان وحماتي في اثيوبيا
السودان طلب تاكيدات من رئاسه الايجاد
بحضور حمايه
لم يتلقى اي اجابه واضح انه لم تستطيعوا
ان يتواصلوا معه
متواري عن المشهد وغائب تماما وغير قادر
على التواصل مع اي جهه موزي يوم 18 مايو
الماضي وبالتالي تحولوا الى الخطه
وحاولوا ان يضعوا املاءات على السودان في
تتعلق ببنود مستفزه تنتهك الاسياده
الوطنيه السودانيه
جرت مع قوى مدنيه موجوده كانت في هذا
الاجتماع هل يؤشر ذلك الى امكانيه تشكيل
حكومه موازيه حكومه في المنفى اعتقد ذلك
نعم هذا سؤال وجيه نعم هذا ممكن ابن مما
هو يعتبر خطوه مهمه وسجاده في هذا
الاجتماع اليوم هو ان المنظمات المدنيه
السودانيه المختلفه المهنيه والتجاريه
المعلمون والاطباء والمحامون كلهم كانوا
ممثلون هنا حل الفراغ هذا
اخر من الحقول المصريه عبر القيمه لدول
زوار السودان يوم الخميس المقبل ونحن
متفائنون بانها تفلح في وضع حل نعج لهذه
الازمه